good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world and so to help you on your journey
today's message is be confident over to
you ASAP Rocky when you sort of first
knew that you had that moment that that
confidence when you felt it when I was
poor man you know it's just like I don't
think confidence is something that you
could buy it's something that's embedded
in you you know and some people gain it
with success that's just like the icing
on a cake but you're poor man with
confidences and stop who almost
invincible a poor man with confidence is
unstoppable I love that quote I love the
message and I agree the next question
then becomes well how do you get that
confidence if you're in a bad
environment if you're poor if you don't
have great people around you how do you
get that confidence and some people may
be born with it I don't know for me it
was much more about changing my
environment and so I got confidence some
of it from my parents believe came from
them they always told me I was Evan cuz
truly Carmichael I could do whatever I
wanted and that gave me a sense of
confidence but if I looked that into my
entrepreneurial career a lot of it came
from my habits and in what I was reading
and now later into the videos by
surrounding myself with people that are
confident that are doing big things not
necessarily in my actual life you know I
don't have a ton of super successful
super confident friends that I hang
around with it's much more from
aspirational mentors and I created the
YouTube channel in part selfishly for
myself the top ten rules selfie for
myself to be around greatness to be
around success on a regular basis and
you can do that for yourself as well if
you want to develop confidence it may
come by watching videos on seven ways to
get more confidence or reading books on
how to be more confident kind of those
tactical how to's but I think a lot of
it also comes from just the environment
just from osmosis just by
around confident people and some of that
wears off on you right it's why I
started to mentor me series let's hang
on people have been a lot more than us
and some of their mindsets and their
beliefs and the way that they think
about things seeps into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves not
to be the next Elon Musk's or Steve Jobs
or whoever but the more confident better
version of ourselves and there was a
point where it really struck me where I
was driving with my father in the car
and I just signed a deal with Stephen
Kelly was the CEO of sage and he runs
you know multi-billion dollar company
with you know ten to fifteen thousand
employees and we're both doing these QA
we're answering questions I'm hosting
the show we get a question from an
entrepreneur he answers if I answer it
and my dad asked me how do you get the
confidence to be on par with Stephen
Kelly that that you know you're his
equal that you're answering questions
alongside him it wasn't in a you sock
kind of town it was a general admiration
like where did that come from like
that's amazing or the supportive way and
I thought about it and it's really from
the videos you know it's really from all
this work cuz I'm hanging around
it's Elon Musk in Kanye West and Snoop
Dogg you know and Martha Stewart and all
of these successful people whether
they're athletes or musicians or
entrepreneurs I'm around that constantly
and so seeing people being confident and
going off and doing great things makes
me be more confident and so by hanging
around greatness more you unleash a
little bit more greatness inside of
yourself as well and the more you do
that and the more consistent you are
with that then the more is going to come
out so I agree that a poor man with
confidence will be unstoppable the
question that becomes how do you get
that confidence and if you weren't born
with it I think that's okay I think
there's so much you can do by changing
your habits by changing your environment
by surrounding yourself with maybe not
people like you may not have people
around you but by resources information
videos guides of confident successful
people that will unleash that inner
boldness and you to go off and do
amazing
so the question today today is I'm
curious how do you get more confidence
for the big things that you're doing in
your life leave it down the comments
below super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick share the two Kiley
Brown aka analogue soul Kiley thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word I really hope you enjoy
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
while I'm in the dressing room five
minutes before I come out my gloves are
laced up I'm breaking my gloves down and
broke I'm pushing the lever on the back
of mine like in the middle of the glove
for my no capir student like I feel my
knuckle piercing against a tight leather
gloves on me
Everlast Bachmann girl and I come out I
have supreme confidence but I'm scared
to death I'm totally afraid I'm afraid
of everything I'm afraid of Luther and
I'm afraid of being a milli aid but I'm
totally confident close I get to ring
more confidence I get closer more
confidence I get the closer more
confidence I get all during my training
I've been afraid of this man I thought
this man might be capable to beat in me
I've dreamed of him being me but I hope
I always stayed afraid of him but it was
close I get to her and I'm more
confident once I'm in the ring I'm a god
no one could beat me
I walk around the ring but I never I
never take my eyes off my opponent I
keep my eyes on even the fees we're
ready and pumping he can't wait to get
his hands on me as well I keep my eyes
on my keep my hands on him I keep my
eyes on them once I see a [ __ ] in his
armor boom one of his eyes may move and
then I know I have them then when it
comes to the center of the Ring he still
looks at me with his piercing looking
that if he's not afraid but he already
made that mistake when when he looked
down for that 1/10 of a second I know I
hadn't he'll fight hard for the first
two or three round I know I really broke
his spirit during the fight I'm
supremely confident I'm moving my head
he throwing punches I'm making the mess
and I'm countering I'm hitting him to
the body I'm punching real hard and I'm
punching and punching and I know he's
not able to take my budget one two three
punches I'm thrown and Bob punches and
lunches he goes down he's out I'm
victorious Mike Tyson greatest fighter
ever lived
[Applause]
were you gonna race after going they are
always confident yeah you can't go in
there thinking aren't about next to me
don't beat me today yeah yeah even if
you know it's gonna beat you you see
I'll be confident yet I'm gonna give him
a run for his money too I won't give my
best you can't worry about anybody else
because he may come out and I'm a really
bad day and then what so you gotta be
ready just in case he has about there
yeah I gotta be got me a game at all
times
yeah feel confident dress to impress
yourself when you leave the house look
at the mirror look at yourself and if
you don't go Diane then you need to
change
feel like a million bucks and that
doesn't mean you have to spend a million
bucks you don't need that Gucci Gucci
Fendi Fendi Prada Prada you can be
rocking that straight 7 to 5 from
Walmart and still be hella hot I'm
saying make sure when you leave the
house you dressed in an outfit that you
feel confident in if you're worrying
about your crack showing and you know
your boobie popping out and you know
your
pants be too tight or too loose or
something you're not gonna feel
confident
each feels sexy you need to kill ha
needs a feel and everyone is beautiful
in their own way so don't give me no BS
book I'm agreeing my hair ugly my skin
is ugly in my and my skin is arguing
everything don't everyone is beautiful
in their own way so give me that crap
okay that means you just need to connect
with your inner swag you can get it
poppin